if I had been doing it for the money was
a grifter and I remember this moment
when I became aware that my thoughts and
opinions were different than most of my
peers and I was like oh it's a choice I
their need to just be honest or I can
I'm smart enough to be able to just pair
it the talking points and be like
reporter you know is it Larry Bird and
that's hilarious when they say that over
in retweets that would be grifting from
for me that would be a grift
this is the Reuben report and according
to the deep state i'm dave rubin quick
reminder guys subscribe to our youtube
channel which gives you just a teeny
tiny chance of actually seeing our
videos all right then joining me today
is a writer a comedian and host of the
dumpster fire right here on YouTube
Bridgette fat Izzie welcome back to the
Reuben report back all right lady you're
back my ghost still here
last time I had you on here you were at
the the beginnings of your political
evolution you were saying I don't know
what's going on with this world you're
trying to make some sense of the world I
still have no idea well a year later or
whatever and barely a year earlier
barely a year you're one of you know
you're on the short list of people that
make some sense to me so what does that
say about me
hey that's terrifying people say this to
me and I'm like you know that that the
world is going crazy of somehow I'm a
voice of reason and I get a lot of so I
guess what's happened is it's true it
has been kind of an exponential I guess
just from like a statistical point of
view and numbers point of view I'm
something like Twitter it has been
exponential rise our growth yeah and
with that comes a lot of criticism and
every good criticism people saying mean
things to you on socially
I know it's strange I I know that this
doesn't affect other people but it
really seems to affect me particular no
but I feel like the criticism I get all
the time is I'm a grifter mm-hmm you
know like I'm some Whig I was one way
and then now I'm another way grifting
but ya know eventually you're gonna need
to knock off this both sides routine in
yards because you're always trying to
just I'm like I'm just being me though
I'm really just confused
yeah do you think that that's sort of
what's working for you more than
anything else like there's enough there
well there's just an upfront Ness about
your evolution like for me something
like five years ago I just started
saying guys I'm a liberal but something
ain't right around here and then it was
just people started going
oh me too and I I sense you're sort of
like just constantly in that my pleasure
no thank you but I think the difference
between us is that you are already kind
of in the political world yeah and what
was your degree in political science
okay so yeah you one of three people
that ever use the political science you
always in college I dropped out so
smoking a lot of pot yeah but I was
blacked out and smoking a lot of pot and
waitressing and I say this to people at
that I you know I talked about the
factory settings and how I think when
you're just when you have your head down
and I didn't know until maybe a cup
maybe last February how I was gonna pay
more than two months worth of bills
ever since when I was 17 so when you
have your head down just trying to
figure that stuff out you're not really
paying attention to the anything else
yeah I was just trying to make money and
wait tables and I moved to LA so that I
could be a content creator I wanted to
write television shows and do comedy and
I didn't I was never I was not aware
there was a culture war going on which
sounds completely naive of me and
Michael MELAS has said to me you know
that just goes to show you how how how
entrenched the cathedral is in terms of
media
and entertainment and academia is that I
didn't even know I was in the Cathedral
right do you sense that getting the
criticism of grifter somehow you're
doing this for money even though as you
said it's just literally a year and a
half ago or you're like you know
scrounging around all that and also you
know it's it's also funny because people
think just cuz like we're on YouTube and
we have a little powder on our faces
that we're like rolling and dough and
it's like I'm not complaining by any
stretch and it was a long time to get
here you know you mean I want it and I'm
just somewhere on my journey as you are
yeah but I find that this thing of like
because a lot of people in our space now
get thrown with grifter or you're doing
it for the money or your cell or
something like that and in a weird way
while that used to bother me now it's
becoming in some ways it's the ultimate
compliment cuz it's almost like they
have nothing left right like there's
nothing left about the ideas that you
put forth or the positions that because
you hold you actually hold a lot of
mixed bag of sort of left-right
positions which I think most people are
yeah all they got is actually is doing
it for the money
money as if you were like oh if I just
stuck out that position over there you
know that's where the money rolls if I
had been doing it for the money was a
grifter and I remember this moment when
I became aware that my thoughts and
opinions were different than most of my
peers and I was like oh it's a choice I
there need to just be honest or I can
I'm smart enough to be able to just pair
it the talking points and be like when
they say that overeats
that would be grifting from for me that
would be a grift because for my idea of
a grift is that I'm not be I'm being
disingenuous I'm being dishonest I'm
saying that I have one thing and I'm
selling another but I'm selling my if
I'm selling anything it's my confusion
wouldn't a grift also be that you would
you would take the easier way out like
it would like clearly I think I think
the people that are in the space that
we're in whatever you want to call that
like this is the road less traveled
right but like if you're on the grift
you don't do the hard thing you do the
easy thing yeah
be easy for me to go in either direction
all in it would also be easy for me to
completely just deep defect and be like
I'm agonize and I always joke that there
are these two strains of Trump
derangement syndrome and I can quit it
like pretty quickly tell if somebody has
one or the other it's if everything is
Trump's fault or Trump can do no wrong
and it's maghen resistance so it's like
the hashtags and they are and I feel
like most people exist in the gray area
in between but they they get so
bombarded by both sides if they dare to
be like well I think there might be you
know I can see this from both sides or
there might be a perspective here that
they just saw like now I'm not I'm just
gonna be quiet so speaking of that it's
a good reason that you are now because I
know you're an expert in foreign policy
especially especially related to Iran
right that's your specific expertise I'm
here know that obviously is not true but
actually often in the morning when I
wake up and I have in my coffee and I'm
just sort of like slowly getting online
and I'm trying to get my thoughts
centered well I'll shoot you some taxi
or go back and forth a little bit and
one of the things over the last couple
weeks that like consistently comes up is
like the craziness related to every
single person on Twitter but I don't
wanna make this just about Twitter but
like the need for all the celebrities
all of the journalists yeah you know
air-quote journalists and just everybody
to have to have a opinion on everything
at all times remember I mean obliques
ago we were in world wars they were so
bad though that World War three go for
you about well I walk my dog that's a
crazy thing and and we kind of talked
about this on dumpster fire my youtube
show which just makes fun of it my whole
thing with dumpster fires like we just
want to laugh while the world burns
because in the moment when news is
breaking and having it is diplomacy by
Twitter now so there there is serious
you know our there's news breaking the
president's tweeting a flag than the
ambassador to the Supreme Leader is
tweeting their flat these are I mean my
roommate
Samantha said of perfectly she said its
Enders game meets wrist got better
perfect description yeah and I think
that there so there is this real people
are getting hurt people are affected by
this it's all playing out virtually and
then you close your computer to put your
phone out and walk outside and say dude
they did it to do right nothing's going
on and the majority of people have no
idea they're not like living in that but
if you're in that moment and the news
cycle is it's all breaking and
everybody's got their takes and the
journalists are all trying to figure it
out and they're waiting for the Pentagon
to confirm things so that they can
confirm the rumors there you get that
kind of rush what do you make of these
people that literally something happens
now and then they have the exact
opposite reaction because it was another
administration five years ago I'm not
talking about somebody that's evolved
over time with their political ideas
right I'm talking about well Trump
didn't have congressional authorization
and then there's literally five years
ago their tweet when they were
completely for Libya I mean Nancy Pelosi
is a great example Trump didn't need I
don't even mean just the people in
politics yeah but there's a video right
now that's been going around that I've
shared of Pelosi five years ago or
whatever it is six years ago saying
Trump didn't Obama didn't need
congressional authorization we toppled
Yanbian regime in Qaddafi now he needs
it like but then everyone just flips on
every little thing because it's all it's
all sports if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about comedy instead of the non-stop
yelling you get everywhere else check
out our comedy playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell